So on the program before I've done several
videos sort of analyzing and dissecting these
apples.
Absolutely ridiculous and embarrassing, very
ignorant interviews that our president has
given.
And most of those interviews have been a pretty
huge interest to the audience, which is good.
I mean, it's good that when I do a dissection
of an interview and really go into detail
about what is being implied, what is said,
what is not said, the sort of broader, uh,
circumstances in which these interviews are
taking place.
It's good that that does well because it just
signals that the audience is actually interested
in going beyond just the most superficial
stuff that happens in American politics.
A lot of those interviews have gotten, you
know, 500,000 views on youtube.
It's 750,000 some I think some of those analyses
have even gotten like a million views on youtube.
Those all pale in comparison to an Oval Office
interview that Donald Trump just gave to ABC
news and George Stephanopoulos.
That doesn't require really anything beyond
just the most superficial analysis because
at its core, what Donald Trump is saying is
that he's willing to collude with foreign
countries that are interested in helping him
win the 2020 election.
Donald Trump saying to the extent that colluding
with foreign countries, uh, is criminal, whether
it's conspiracy to collude or a Molly moon's
violations, receiving things of value.
He's interested in doing that in 2020, if
anybody has dirt on potential 2020 opponents
for him and he wouldn't go to the FBI.
So let's just kind of back up and set this
up.
Uh, George Stephanopoulos asking Donald Trump
about, given everything that happened in 2016
if countries came to you in 2020 with dirt
on your opponents, what would you do?
Let's check out the first piece of this absolutely
insane video.
Your son Don Junior, is that before the Senate
intelligence committee today.
And again, he was not charged with anything
in retrospect that not only wasn't he charge,
if you read it with all of the horrible fake
news, I mean I was reading that my son was
going to go to jail.
This is a good young man that he was going
to go to jail and then the report comes out
and they didn't even say [inaudible] going
to the FBI when he got that in.
Okay, let's put yourself in a position.
You're a congressman.
Somebody comes up and says, Hey, I have information
on your opponent.
Do you call the FBI?
I don't think coming from the day one you
do.
I've seen a lot of things over my life.
I don't think in my whole life I've ever called
the FBI and my whole life I don't.
You don't call the FBI, you throw somebody
out of office, you do whatever you can go
or got or stolen briefing book.
He called the FBI.
Well, that's different is stolen briefing,
but this isn't a stuff.
This is somebody that said, we have information
on your opponent.
Trump's right.
The, the initial information that he was offered
in the Trump tower meeting might not have
been stolen, but then he asked Russia to steal
information.
He's acting like the theft of the information
is relevant, but he asked for information
on Hillary and the DNC to be illegally hacked
and stolen.
Can you obtain those 30,000 missing emails?
You'll be rewarded for it.
Russia, if you're listening, we'll play that
clip later on, but let's go back just a few
seconds here in the George Stephanopoulos
interview and pick it back up.
Well, that's different, this stolen briefing,
but this isn't a story.
This is somebody that said, we have information
on your opponent.
Oh, let me call the FDA.
Give me a break.
Life as a work.
Your director says that's what should happen.
The FBI director is wrong.
Your campaign this time around foreigners.
If Russia, if China, if someone else offers
you information upon it, should they accept
it or should they call the FBI?
I think maybe you do both.
I think you might want to listen.
I don't, there's nothing wrong with listening.
If somebody called trauma country Norway,
we have information on your opponent.
Oh, I think I'd want to hear it.
You want that kind of interference in our
elections.
It's not an interference.
They have information.
I think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong.
I go maybe to the FBI if I thought there was
But when somebody comes up with oppo research,
right, they come up with up or research, oh,
let's call the FBI.
The FBI doesn't have enough agents to take
care of it.
But you go and talk honestly to congressmen.
They all do it.
They always have, and that's the way it is.
It's called oppo research.
That's right.
He would do it again.
I mean, truly congratulations to George Stephanopoulos
for this interview at a really good job done
by him.
Uh, eliciting all of the things that we feared
most, but sort of anticipated Donald Trump
would say about this.
Even with that speech pattern.
Have you noticed that when Donald Trump picks
up on a word or phrase that he likes, he'll
then use it repeatedly three or four times
in a minute?
Sometimes in this case oppo research.
It's a very unusual speech pattern that he
has, which we have talked about before and
we could get into, but it's popping up here
again.
But to get to the core of the substance here,
understand what is taking place.
Donald Trump wants us to believe he didn't
collude in 2016 he didn't know anything about
Russian help for his campaign.
He had no idea that Russia wanted him to be
elected president over Hillary Clinton.
He's totally innocent in all ways.
But if this time around Russia came around
with information forum about whoever is going
to be his 2020 opponent, he would absolutely
take it and he probably wouldn't go to the
FBI would that nothing says no collusion with
Russia, like admitting that you're open to
collusion with in 2020.
And this is why there have to be consequences
because without them, not only does Donald
Trump get away with it in 2016, which he did
and he's going to, uh, he actually becomes
emboldened like a little kid and says, I do
it in 2020 as well.
And a conservative David from had some interesting
tweets about this.
He says, this is like a smoking gun tape of
Nixon confessing on national television.
David from tweeted, quote like the smoking
gun tape, if Nixon had confessed on national
television to a network anchor instead of
in the secrecy of the Oval Office to his most
trusted aide, immediately after this clip
of the George Stephanopoulos interview went
live.
The hashtag impeached Trump now immediately
trending on Twitter after the interview was
published.
But I hate to break it to you.
If you see this interview and you see what
Donald Trump says about 2020 collusion with
foreign countries and you're shocked, you're
either not paying attention or deliberately
ignorant because if any of this is shocking,
you haven't read the Mueller report.
Because all of this willingness to engage
in this type of behavior is in the report.
If you go by the bar letter and then you see
Donald Trump say this, you might actually
experience a moment of cognitive dissonance.
How can it be?
Barr?
Said, no collusion, no obstruction, everything's
great.
The problem was the investigation, not Trump's
behavior.
Uh, and then you see Trump say, oh, I, I would,
I would accept a information about my opponents
from foreign countries in 2020.
You might see that as a contradiction.
If you just read what's in the molar report,
you would say, oh yeah, this fits perfectly.
This is exactly what Mueller found Donald
Trump and the people around him were willing
to do.
And we're doing.
And as conservative David from also added
on Twitter quote, anybody still believe that
don jr did not pre clear his Trump tower meeting
with Russian agents with his father first.
I've been saying this from the get go, whatever
criminality does or doesn't exist in the Trump
tower meeting with Natalia vessel and that
sky, that's not at issue here.
The question is, we were told that Donald
Trump had no idea that that meeting was being
planned, that that meeting was happening,
that that meeting took place until much, much
later.
And I said from the get go, that's not believable.
There's no way that that's the truth.
And once again, Donald Trump's answer here,
so clear, so concise.
Of course.
Yeah, I would take the help and I wouldn't
tell the FBI.
Do any of us believe Trump didn't know that
that Trump tower meeting was in development
of before it took place?
I don't believe it for a second.
Why is it that our president is regularly
choosing other countries over hours?
Trump says he would have no responsibility
if a foreign country that's outside of our
democratic system comes to him as a sitting
president with on other candidates that he
would have no responsibility to go to the
FBI.
That is responsibility, would effectively
be to use that information to win rather than
to try to stop the foreign interference on
our elections.
This is an open invitation for other countries
to now try to ingratiate themselves with Trump
in this particular way.
It's another signal to Russia or to whoever
else that the door is open.
Trump wants to hear from you.
Does nobody understand that?
What Donald Trump is saying in this interview
with George Stephanopoulos is effectively
the same thing as when he said this during
the 2016 campaign.
I will tell you this, Russia, if you're listening,
I hope you're able to find the 30,000 emails
that are missing.
I think you will probably be rewarded mightily
by our press.
Let's see if that happens.
That'll be next year.
This interview is that all over again with
different vocabulary and Trump as the sitting
president, rather than Trump is merely a candidate.
The Oval Office is not secure.
The 2020 election is obviously not safe and
the psychology that we have to apply here
is child psychology.
I've been reading the book influence by Robert
Cialdini.
It's a real classic from 1984 I've never read
it before.
I'm finally getting around to it.
And the elements in the book, uh, based on
the influence and child psychology are very
relevant here.
When a little kid gets away with something
and their misdeeds go unpunished, they become
emboldened not just to repeat those misdeeds,
but to take them further and see how far they
can actually get.
This is how children behave and incredibly,
this is the psychological framework that we
need to apply to Donald Trump.
George W. Bush was a terrible president.
I don't think he was, uh, uh, uh, anything
like Donald Trump though when it comes to,
we have to deal with Donald Trump.
Like we deal with little kids.
You didn't have to deal with Donald, with
George W. Bush.
Like you were dealing with a little kid.
You had to deal with them like you were dealing
with a, uh, an individual who has weaponized
neoliberalism and a foreign policy, um, for
political gain, but you didn't have to deal
with them like you deal with the little kid
in the way that you do with Donald Trump.
And that's what we're dealing with here.
Are we going to allow all of this to continue
with no consequences?
I hope the answer is no.
Unfortunately.
I believe the answer is yes.
And, uh, I want to hear from you.
What do you think about this?
Just incredible, incredible interview with
George Stephanopoulos.
Let me know.
Follow me on that
Twitter and send me a tweet there at the pacman.
The show is also on Twitter at David Pakman
show,